non-minimalists
how do i make my boss spontaneously
combust well thankfully you don't have a
boss
i'm kidding
yeah i i understand this um this
sentiment ryan and i
had a um
a tyrannical boss we'll call him don
and um
man he
brought a lot of misery to our lives
yeah he had certain expectations of us
that were never we weren't able to meet
because it was a sliding expectation
scale so as soon as you met the
expectation
it was never enough or if it was enough
it was enough for a moment
and you may if you're lucky
get a pat on the back but really the
reward was to stop being yelled at he in
fact the very first meeting i was in
with him
i was on the phone and it was me and the
other regional managers
and he called us [ __ ] on the very
first meeting
i'm like oh this is setting a tone here
yeah
yeah
and and what i recognized is
i mean
it calls me cech
anguish and this is why i really
identify with alex's question here it
calls me so much
mental
stress
my anxiety was through the roof because
of him
because of his expectations but also
realizing oh i'm i didn't realize it at
the time i realized that in retrospect
only i was making myself upset yeah
would it have been possible for me to a
walk away sooner yes for sure
but also
i could have just put my foot down and
said hey no i'm not going to tolerate
this because here's the lesson to get
from this
you get what you tolerate yeah and so
how do you make yours your ball
spontaneously combust
well you ask that question
if my ball sort of spontaneously combust
today would i replace him with hit with
the exact same version of him or
would i feel relief and if the answer is
i would feel relief
you got to walk away
yeah i mean that's difficult especially
like if you got a
high salary and i'm just trying to have
some like sympathy here for you know
someone who is providing for their
family and they're relying on the salary
so yeah walk away um
but yeah it's not walk away and start a
podcast walk away and start a blog it
could be that but it's having some sort
of plan to yeah to replace the salary
but you're never going to to get that if
it's just constantly wondering i love
how
uh you brought up the the tolerance
because now i want to go back in time
and the first time he yelled at me i
just want to be like
dude in what world
do you think it's okay to talk to me
like that
like we have an employee employ a
employee employer relationship right i'm
not your whip i'm not your whipping boy
yeah yeah
um and it would have changed the dynamic
and he would have probably tried to find
a way to
yeah demote or whatever but like we were
so good at what we did
it would have been
nearly impossible for him to do that
without making up lies or something else
right yeah and so
yes i think the the thing to recognize
here is quite often we are miserable
because we tolerate
the things that are making us miserable
yeah so it's not really yeah it's not
your boss it's it's you who is putting
up with it and when i hear this question
you know you could ask the same question
about like how do i make my
mother spontaneously combust yes
and in that situation it's very easy to
see like oh i have to like love that
person from a distance
you know if the relationship can't be
healed um but it's the same thing with
your boss it's like
you know maybe uh you don't have to
leave your job but how can you
create some distance between you and
your boss while setting the expectation
of uh not being treated like like
garbage yeah yeah and so there might be
some boundaries to come in as you walk
away because walking away isn't blowing
it up necessarily what's my contingency
plan maybe i'm going to start putting
out resumes and feelers and there is a
huge hiring shortage all over the place
this is one of the best times ever
to find many different
positions throughout many different
industries right now there's so many
people recognizing that it's not just
about the money anymore money is a part
of the equation right but there are
people who want to do more meaningful
work they want to create something that
they feel they have a sense of autonomy
and mastery and freedom in doing they're
a part of something that has some sort
of purpose next week we're talking to
ken coleman about his new book
from paycheck to purpose
because it's no longer just about the
paycheck right that's a piece of it and
let's not pretend it's not yeah we work
to earn
money yes but we don't work only to earn
money yeah i like how you put it uh with
you know being in a car it's like
we can't stay here and pretend that
money isn't like a passenger in this
vehicle right but it's certainly not in
the driver's seat yeah don't let money
behind the wheel cause it's gonna steer
you into all kinds of places you don't
want to go yeah
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free